.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Mitte Juli am Matterhorn.
Die Touristen
strömen hinauf zur Hörnlihütte.
Um dem Berg nahezukommen.
Ich schaue mal,
wie sie dann weiterkommen.
In diesem Hitzesommer
ist das Matterhorn
so ausgeapert wie sonst nie.
Das birgt Gefahren
für die Bergsteiger.
In der Hörnlihütte kontrolliert
das Hüttenwartehepaar die Situation.
Hier übernachtet,
wer aufs Matterhorn will.
Wenn die Temperaturen so bleiben,
besteht die Gefahr
von vermehrtem Steinschlag.
Dann müsste man
die Situation überdenken.
Das ist Eis, das abbricht.
Dies ist die Geschichte des ersten
Hitzewochenendes in diesem Sommer
auf der Hörnlihütte am Matterhorn.
Hüttenwartin Edith hat ein Problem:
Ja, wir hätten Arbeit gehabt.
Aber auch
von der körperlichen Situation her
war er sicher nicht geeignet,
um rauf- und runterzulaufen.
Es ist trotzdem schade,
hat er aufgegeben. Aber du ...
Jetzt probieren wir ...
Nein, einen Koch habe ich ja.
Einen Jungkoch. Wir schauen mit ihm.
Jetzt suchen wir Lösungen
oder wenigstens Leute,
die seine Freitage abdecken kommen.
Ein Koch ist auf der Hörnlihütte
kurzfristig abgesprungen.
Und das ausgerechnet
am ersten Sommerferienwochenende.
Wir sollten schauen,
ob wir für morgen noch
einen Heliflug organisieren können,
der uns noch Material bringt.
Schau mit der Air Zermatt!
Wir brauchen sicher Getränke
und etwas Gemüse.
Das Ehepaar Edith und Martin Lehner
führt die Hütte seit vier Jahren.
Dann rufe ich
bei der Air Zermatt an.
Dann schauen wir
wegen des Mittagessens,
ob wir alle abfertigen können.
Hallo, hier ist Edith
von der Hörnlihütte.
Könnten wir morgen
noch einen Unterlastflug haben?
Edith Lehner ist eigentlich
gelernte Pflegefachfrau.
Am liebsten früh am Morgen,
wegen der Temperaturen,
damit wir
die Kühlkette einhalten können.
7.30 Uhr? Ja, das wäre sensationell.
Die Hörnlihütte
ist ein Wander-Hotspot in Zermatt.
Noch 280 kg.
Was am Berg ist, kann ich
abschätzen mit den Vorreservationen.
Aber der Tagestourismus ...
Gerade am Wochenende erwarten wir
wetterbedingt viele Leute -
Familien
und Tagesausflügler aus dem Tal.
Es ist Vormittag
und noch ist es ruhig.
Darum hat Martin Lehner Zeit,
uns etwas zu zeigen,
worauf er stolz ist.
Das ist unser neuer
The #1 Matterhornist.
Vor zwei, drei Jahren begannen
die Hüttenmädchen zu schauen,
wer im Sommer
am öftesten am Matterhorn ist.
Dieses Jahr habe ich
das von meinem Vater ausgedruckt.
Er ist
ein richtiges Matterhorn-Urgestein.
Er war sehr oft am Matterhorn,
es war sein Berg.
Er führte am liebsten
aufs Matterhorn.
Viele Berge
hat er gar nicht bestiegen,
aber das Matterhorn war seine Welt.
250 Fr. kostete damals die Besteigung
des Matterhorns mit Führer.
Heute sind es über 1'500 Fr.
Martin ist, wie sein Vater,
auch Bergführer.
Vor fünf Jahren fragte uns
der Vorgänger dieser Hütte an.
Martin
wollte anfangs eigentlich nicht.
Ich wusste, dass die Hörnlihütte
ein Hotspot ist.
Da wird viel los sein: am Berg,
im Service, bei der Rettung.
Hier ist wirklich
immer sehr viel los.
Der zweite Punkt für mich war,
dass ich den Sommer verliere.
Ich wusste, dass mit einer Zusage
das Bergführen im Sommer
für mich gestorben ist.
Das war schon ein Schritt,
über den ich nachdenken musste,
ob ich ihn machen möchte oder nicht.
Es wird Mittag.
Der Hüttenstress beginnt.
Die Hörnlihütte
lebt von der Nähe zum Matterhorn.
Direkt hinter der Hütte
beginnt die Kletterei.
Bei uns steht das Matterhorn
in Disneyland.
Südkalifornier träumen davon, das
richtige Matterhorn zu besteigen.
Zweimal Rösti mit Ei!
Bis zu 150 Gäste
müssen über Mittag verpflegt werden.
Der einzig verbliebene Koch Freddy
und sein Helfer Peter sind gefordert.
Sieben Mitarbeitende hat die Chefin.
Das ist unsere Abwaschstrasse.
Hier muss jeder mal hin.
Es ist nicht der beliebteste Job.
Er kommt gleich nach WC-Putzen.
Aber es ist halt so, jeder muss
alles machen. Nur der Koch nicht.
Bolognese mit Gemüse,
dann Rösti, Ei, Speck.
Ist es machbar allein?
- Ich bin schon froh um Peter.
Ganz allein ginge es nicht.
Und ich möchte auch mal freihaben.
Die Hörnlihütte
hat nicht nur viele Tagesgäste,
sondern auch noch 150 Betten
zum Übernachten.
In diesen heissen Tagen sorgt sich
Martin um die Wasserversorgung.
Ich schaue,
ob bei der Fassung Wasser kommt.
Das Schmelzwasser
der umliegenden Gletscher
ist die einzige Wasserquelle.
Ein bisschen Wasser kommt noch.
An schönen Tagen verbraucht die Hütte
fast 6'000 l Wasser,
das hochgepumpt wird.
Ein grosser Teil davon:
die WC-Spülung.
Martin ist für alles verantwortlich.
Als die Hütte
vor sieben Jahren neu gebaut wurde,
war hinter der Fassung
noch ein kleiner Gletscher.
Der ist jetzt weg.
Normalerweise reichte es
mit dem schmelzenden Schnee,
der oben in der Seite drin war.
Aber dieses Jahr
gab es keinen Schnee,
sodass es am Austrocknen ist.
Aber wenn es 24 Std. läuft,
sollte das Wasser
für die nächsten Tage reichen.
Aber nachher muss man schauen.
Eigentlich
ist Martin gelernter Schreiner,
muss nun aber auch die Technik
im Griff haben.
Wir beziehen eigentlich
den gesamten Strom aus Batterien.
Es läuft alles über die Batterien.
In diesem Raum ist es immer warm.
Es produziert eine gewisse Wärme.
Hier sind die Batterien.
Generator und Solaranlage
laden die Batterien.
Von hier nehmen wir
den Strom für das ganze Haus.
Hallo Debbie!
Die jüngste Tochter Debbie kommt
für das Wochenende aus dem Tal hoch.
Hallo Deborah! Sie hört mich nicht.
Die Jungen haben die Stöpsel drin.
Lehners leben eigentlich in Zermatt.
Die drei Kinder kommen oft hoch,
um zu helfen.
Es ist heiss heute, gell? Hallo!
Alles gut?
- Ja.
Wie lange hattest du?
- Eine Stunde.
Gibst du mir die Medikamente
für Papa, damit wir ihn wieder ...
Das ist
so ein bisschen eine Wundertüte,
die hoffentlich
auch Wunder wirkt bis morgen.
Martin hat seit Tagen
starke Rückenschmerzen.
Edith hat Medikamente organisiert.
Ich bin hinten
ein bisschen blockiert.
Zum Glück habe ich eine Frau,
die mit Nadeln umzugehen weiss.
Wir schauen mal,
ob es morgen wieder besser geht.
Sonst gehe ich
dann mal noch in eine Massage.
Es ist inzwischen 16.30 Uhr.
Die Bergführer kommen hoch für die
Tour aufs Matterhorn am nächsten Tag.
Denis Gruber ist Zermatter Bergführer
und viel hier oben.
Ciao, Denis! Herzlich willkommen!
Wie geht es?
- Gut, und dir?
Schön, bist du hier.
Die Bergführer
erfahren oft erst am Abend vorher,
wen sie aufs Matterhorn führen.
Wir treffen uns um 18 Uhr.
Dann werden wir sehen, wie es ist.
Meistens ist es so,
dass ich mit ihm spreche,
um herauszufinden,
was er schon gemacht hat.
Die Leute,
die mit uns aufs Matterhorn kommen,
müssen eine Vorbereitungstour
vorweisen oder diese mit uns machen.
Merci, Vivien!
Viele Bergführer
bringen Geschenke aus dem Tal.
Das ist unser Kavalier.
Er bringt uns immer Schnittblumen.
Das freut uns immer sehr.
Vielen Dank, auch an dich, Vivien!
So etwas ist hier oben eine Rarität.
Vielen Dank!
Schauen wir!
Das ist unser Blumenkavalier.
Ihn hast du zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Die Hörnlihütte
gehört der Burgergemeinde Zermatt.
Darum haben
die einheimischen Bergführer
in der Hütte ihr eigenes Zimmer.
Ja ...
Meinst du, ich muss schauen, ob
gewisse Leute noch am Schlafen sind?
Wenn einer mehrere Male
ans Matterhorn geht ...
... kommt er gegen Mittag zurück
und isst mit den Gästen.
Am besten erholen kann er sich
am Nachmittag mit etwas Schlaf,
bis dann der nächste Gast kommt.
Hat man hier sein privates Bett?
- Man hat bevorzugte Betten.
Meistens nimmt man das gleiche Bett.
Man erkennt es daran, dass oft
noch Material unter dem Bett ist.
Anfangs Saison muss man
halt schauen, wo die Sachen sind.
Ist das vom letzten Jahr?
- Ja.
Meistens lässt man das Material
den Winter über hier.
Man muss keine Angst haben,
dass etwas zerfressen wird.
Wie sind
die Verhältnisse am Matterhorn?
Wie sie uns sagten,
ist es momentan sehr trocken.
Das hat den Vorteil, dass man
weniger Steigeisen laufen muss.
Der Nachteil:
Sobald im Dach der Schnee weg ist,
kann es Steinschlag geben.
Das muss man im Auge behalten.
Aber im Moment sei das noch okay.
Jeder Tag muss neu beurteilt werden.
Weil es so warm ist,
kann es sich jederzeit ändern.
Denis trifft
zum ersten Mal seine Gäste,
die er und ein Kollege
aufs Matterhorn führen werden.
Es sind
zwei Franzosen aus Strassburg.
Ciao!
- Denis.
Greg, enchanté!
Seid ihr gut angekommen?
- Tipptopp.
Seid ihr in Form?
Ja, und bereit.
Wir hoffen,
mit ihm auf den Gipfel zu kommen.
Am Matterhorn hat jeder Führer
nur einen Gast am Seil.
Ein Kollege von Denis
wird am Abend dazustossen.
Wie ist der erste Eindruck?
Sie wollen unbedingt auf den Berg.
Ich musste sie ein bisschen bremsen.
Ich sagte ihnen, sie sollen sich
nicht zu viel Druck machen.
Diejenigen,
die unbedingt auf den Berg wollen,
machen sich meistens zu viel Druck.
Ich nehme auch ein Glas.
Santé!
* Lachen *
Schön, seid ihr hier!
Martin informiert die Bergführer
jeden Abend
über die Verhältnisse am Berg.
Ich sage es zuerst
auf Walliserdeutsch ...
... dann auf Französisch
und auf Englisch.
Um 3.30 Uhr gibt es Frühstück.
Bitte kommt nicht vorher herunter!
Um 3.30 Uhr
geht ihr in den Frühstücksraum.
Um 3.50 Uhr
ist morgen Turbo der Leadguide.
Ihr dürft nicht losgehen,
bevor er das Seil nicht parat hat.
Die Verhältnisse am Berg
sind eigentlich sehr gut.
Das haben die Kameraden, die
heute zurückgekommen sind, erzählt.
Dieses Jahr
hat es nicht mehr viel Schnee.
Gestern sagten wir, dass man beim
Hochgehen am kurzen Seil gehen muss.
Beim Runtergehen müsst ihr auf euren
Gast achten und selber entscheiden.
Es ist Hochsaison.
Trotzdem sind wenig Leute am Berg.
Ob das damit zu tun hat,
dass an vielen Orten in den Alpen
schon über die Steinschlaggefahr
diskutiert wird?
Wir haben nicht kommuniziert,
dass das Matterhorn gefährlich sei,
wie es momentan
vom Mont Blanc kommuniziert wird.
Dort sind die Probleme
z.T. bereits so gross,
dass die Hüttenzustiege
nicht mehr gewährleistet sind.
Bei uns ist es
eigentlich noch ruhig.
Nervös?
Es geht steiler hoch, als man denkt.
Nein, nein.
- Es sieht so aus.
Dort ist jemand am Absteigen.
Unten hat es ein Fixseil.
Wir gehen hinten
um die Hütte herum.
Auch Vater Andreas
will morgen mit seinem 14-jährigen
Sohn Linus aufs Matterhorn.
Oben nimmst du Steigeisen
und dann am Fixseil bis aufs Dach.
Bist du nervös?
- Ein bisschen.
Das Matterhorn
ist nicht zu unterschätzen.
Hier gibt es mehr Todesfälle
als an jedem anderen Schweizer Berg.
Diese Bergsteiger
waren heute 14 Std. lang unterwegs.
Zwei italienische Studenten:
Der Abstieg war furchtbar.
Es ist viel einfacher, hochzugehen,
als runterzukommen.
Man kommt schnell von der Route ab.
Wir haben uns
zweimal im Abstieg verstiegen
und jedes Mal
hat uns das 1 1/2 Std. gekostet.
Das Hüttenpaar verfolgt,
was am Berg passiert.
Ihr wart auf dem Matterhorn?
- Ja.
Und was ist jetzt euer Plan?
- Nach Hause gehen.
In der Hütte zu übernachten,
kommt für sie nicht infrage.
150 Euro pro Nacht
sind ganz schön viel.
Wir können uns das nicht leisten.
Die neue Hütte ist tatsächlich
fast doppelt so teuer wie früher.
Und campieren ist jetzt verboten.
Ihnen bleibt nur der fünfstündige
Abstieg nach Zermatt,
da die Bahn nicht mehr fährt.
Der Tag neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Doch Martins Rückenschmerzen
müssen noch behandelt werden.
Da ich
Anästhesie-Pflegefachfrau bin,
ist es für mich kein Problem,
ihn zu spritzen,
damit er
morgen wieder arbeiten kann.
Das ist in Gottes Namen so:
Hier oben werden die Leute gedopt,
damit sie am nächsten Tag
wieder liefern können.
Etwas zur Entspannung der Muskeln.
- Das ist ein Riesencocktail.
Er muss ja auch wirken. Gut, komm!
* Mystische Musik *
Um 21 Uhr gehen die meisten
Bergsteiger schon ins Bett.
Alles ist ruhig.
Doch um 22.15 Uhr
ein Spätankömmling -
aufgebrochen
heute Morgen in Mailand.
Hallo! Was machst du denn hier?
Überleben.
- Wo kommst du her?
Ich habe die letzte Bahn
am Schwarzsee verpasst.
Hast du eine Reservation?
- Ja, mein Name ist Moises Martinez.
Gehst du morgen aufs Matterhorn?
Wenn es geht, würde ich
noch eine Zusatznacht buchen
und morgen Pause machen.
Gehst du allein aufs Matterhorn?
Ja, allein.
Du bist in Zimmer 23.
Allein,
denn alle anderen schlafen bereits.
Der Koch ist schon
seit vielen Stunden auf den Beinen.
Trotzdem macht er sich
nochmals an die Arbeit.
Nochmals ein kleines Menu:
Kartoffelstock, Bohnen,
Saurer Mocken.
Er sah megahungrig aus. Den kann man
so nicht ins Bett gehen lassen.
Zwei Nächte ruhen und dann aufs
Matterhorn, dies der Plan von Moises.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wir machen schon mal etwas Licht.
Tagwacht für die Hüttencrew.
Frühstückszeit für die Bergsteiger.
Wollt ihr das Wasser tragen
oder unten dran tun, Girls?
Achtung, heiss!
Gestern hochgekommen
und schon wieder wach?
Ja.
- Macht das nichts?
Ich bin nicht so der Morgenmensch,
aber ab und zu ist es egal.
3.20 Uhr:
Der Zermatter Bergführer Denis ist
einer der Ersten, der herunterkommt.
In der neuen Hütte
gilt ein strikter Zeitplan.
Früher ging das Licht an
und 10 Min. später
waren die Leute weg.
Es war Stress. Jetzt hat man
15 Min. Zeit fürs Frühstück.
Das ist auch nicht sehr lang,
aber du deponierst den Rucksack
und hast alles bereits parat.
Am Morgen gehst du aufs WC
und dann geht es los.
Vater Andreas und Sohn Linus
sind auch wach.
Gut geschlafen?
Ich denke schon.
- Tipptopp.
Niemand darf starten,
bevor der Leadguide Turbo
um 3.45 Uhr vom Tisch aufsteht.
Zuerst starten
die einheimischen Bergführer,
dann die auswärtigen,
zuletzt diejenigen ohne Führer.
Morgen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Um 3.50 Uhr ist es so weit.
Macht es gut! Tschüss zusammen!
Viel Glück!
An zweiter Stelle:
Denis mit einem Franzosen.
Bye-bye! See you later!
A bientôt! Bonne chance!
Jetzt kommen der Vater und der Sohn.
Ihr seid nicht im Stress.
- Nein.
Es ist schon speziell, oder?
- Dort muss man sowieso anstehen.
Direkt hinter der Hütte
ist der steile Einstieg.
86 Bergsteiger sind heute gestartet.
Manchmal sind es über 100.
Normal hat es eine Kolonne
bis zum Hügel dort hinten.
Etwa 8 Std. wird die Tour
für Vater und Sohn dauern.
Nur wenige gehen ohne Bergführer:
Ich bin allein.
Dort hinten ist noch jemand allein.
Was ist der Plan?
Wenn ich mich gut fühle,
gehe ich auf den Gipfel,
wenn nicht, kehre ich um.
Good luck!
- Thank you.
2 Std. später.
Eigentlich hätte Martin
Edith jetzt ablösen sollen.
Lehni ist leicht komatös.
Nein, ich glaube, er hat einfach
einmal sehr gut geschlafen.
Er hörte weder das Handy
noch das Telefon noch den Wecker
noch den Generator,
der um 7 Uhr ziemlich brummt.
Wir gönnen ihm diesen Schlaf
und lassen ihn noch.
vielleicht
ist er dann wieder leistungsfähig.
Hello!
- Guten Morgen!
Um 7.30 Uhr ist der Versorgungsflug
der Air Zermatt angekündigt.
Ich höre nichts.
Kein Funkverkehr, nichts.
Ich bin natürlich froh,
wenn er das mit dem Wasser
und dem Generator macht.
Und er ist froh,
wenn ich das Büro mache.
Den Rest sollten wir gegenseitig
abdecken können.
650 kg Getränke und Essen.
Eier, vorsichtig!
Jeden zweiten Tag
gibt es einen Versorgungsflug.
90 Eier sind gekommen. 100 Joghurt.
Joghurt sollten noch mehr kommen.
Vollmilch sind es vier Kartons.
Guten Morgen!
Ich habe einen Heli gehört.
- Wie geht es dir? Guten Morgen!
Du warst ja komatös.
Ich habe es aus dem Bett geschafft.
- Wie geht es? Besser?
Doch.
- Du konntest wieder mal schlafen.
Ja, ich konnte schlafen.
- Dann trink jetzt einen Kaffee!
Wo ist mein ...
Ich habe alles weggeräumt,
damit du schlafen kannst.
Ich habe noch Muskelkater.
Die letzten zwei, drei Tage
habe ich ein bisschen ...
Aber die Spannung ist weg.
Ich muss sie mal fragen,
was sie gespritzt hat.
Es bleibt wenig Zeit,
um die Hütte zu putzen.
Moises, der Spätankömmling, ist wach.
Guten Morgen! Eigentlich
ist nur noch er im Zimmer.
Niemand hat zwei Nächte gebucht.
- Doch, er. Er ist in der 23.
Dann machst du das WC?
- Ja.
Okay.
Die neue Hörnlihütte ist mehr
ein Hotel als eine Berghütte.
Dazu gehören Duschen und WCs
mit fliessendem Wasser
in über 3'000 m Höhe.
Oben ans Bett. Und hopp!
Edith sagte, ich solle mit
dem Kissen ein Matterhörnli machen.
Martin und ich
haben eine Luxusvariante.
Uns hat man
ein grosses Zimmer gegeben.
Auch für uns
ist so eine Luxusvariante
in einer Berghütte sehr ungewohnt.
Aber wir geniessen es.
Es ist ein Rückzugsort,
auch wenn es nicht oft passiert,
dass wir hier sind.
Es ist wirklich zum Schlafen.
Martin, der Bergführer:
Immer, wenn er Zeit hat,
gilt sein Blick dem Berg.
Es ist erst 9.30 Uhr und schon
kommen die ersten Bergsteiger zurück.
Eigentlich ist es viel zu früh.
Es ist Denis
mit seinem französischen Gast.
Bien fait.
- C'est dur.
War es gut?
Es ging ihm
schon in der Nacht schlecht.
Um Mitternacht musste er erbrechen.
Wir sagten, wir würden
so weit gehen, wie es geht,
bis er spürt,
dass es nicht mehr geht.
Beim Unteren Roten Turm
sind wir umgekehrt.
Zeitlich
waren wir eigentlich gut dran.
Wir gingen
mit gemütlichen Schritten.
Aber dann merkte man,
dass er unsicher zu gehen begann.
Das war sicher
die beste Entscheidung.
Wichtig ist immer,
dass sie es selber auch sehen.
Weit oben auf über 4'000 m
sind die ersten Bergsteiger
im Gipfelbereich sichtbar.
In anderen Jahren
war das Matterhorn um diese
Jahreszeit noch voller Schnee.
Jetzt hat es wegen der Trockenheit
und der Hitze viel Geröll,
das sich auch manchmal löst.
Das macht Denis Sorgen.
Ein Problem
wird sicher zuoberst sein,
wenn es im Dach
keinen Schnee mehr hat.
Wenn es ausapert, kann es sein,
dass es vermehrt Steinschlag gibt
und man
in den Fixseilen darunter ist.
Das ist sicher ein Problem.
Das muss man jeden Tag beobachten.
Wenn man etwas sieht,
muss man die anderen informieren.
Vielleicht wird das Matterhorn
dann halt gesperrt. Worst Case.
Der Berg
steht schon länger unter Beobachtung
nach einem grossen Felsausbruch
im letzten Hitzesommer 2003.
Ciao, Martin!
- Wie geht es? Alles im Griff?
Jan Beutel ist regelmässig
bei Martin in der Hörnlihütte.
Er ist Wissenschaftler und misst seit
dem Ausbruch die Bewegung am Berg.
Das Türmli,
auf das wir am meisten achten,
hält und hält und hält.
Jeder, der es anschaut, denkt,
es stürze morgen ein.
Niemand versteht es.
- Herzlich willkommen!
Trinken wir einen Apéro?
Jan Beutel will heute einen Sensor
für seine Messungen auswechseln,
direkt unter der Hörnlihütte.
Seit über 15 Jahren
sammelt er Livedaten vom Berg,
um einen weiteren Felsabbruch
hoffentlich vorhersagen zu können.
Was ist das jetzt?
Das ist ein Drahtlossensor
für unsere Messstellen oben.
Das ist jetzt nur
ein Wireless-Relay, um zu funken.
Da muss eine neue Batterie rein.
Auch ihn beunruhigt
die derzeitige Hitze.
Denn, wenn der Permafrost auftaut,
sprengt der Wasserdruck den Fels.
Wir sind hier unten
auf der Hörnlihütte.
Wir haben natürlich auch
die Daten der Wetterstation.
Da sehen wir extrem, wie die
letzte Woche immer wärmer wird.
Vorletzte und letzte Nacht
gab es auf 4'000 m Plusgrade.
Das ist extrem ungewöhnlich.
Das ist Stress für den Berg,
das ist Stress pur.
Wenn es nicht einmal in der Nacht,
wenn es wolkenlos ist,
runterkühlen kann,
heizt es den Berg auf.
Das geht in die Tiefe.
Mit einer Verzögerung
kommt diese Wärme in der Tiefe an
und taut dort immer mehr
den gefrorenen Fels auf.
Da kann es dann natürlich schon
zu Instabilitäten kommen.
Auftauender tiefer Permafrost
ist die eine Gefahr.
Fehlendes Eis an der Oberfläche
die andere.
Wenn kein Eis mehr
die Geröllschichten bedeckt,
steigt die Steinschlaggefahr -
ausgelöst durch die Bergsteiger.
Martin erkundigt sich bei den
Kollegen jeden Tag, wie es aussieht,
speziell am Gipfel.
Wie war das Dach? War es noch gut?
- Es war schon gut.
Ich denke, es ist schlechter, wenn
es plötzlich keinen Schnee mehr hat.
Das ist dann eben das Problem.
- Wenn es Schutt hat, gell?
Solange es das Eis
noch nicht nimmt, geht es.
Aber es könnte sein,
dass es das Eis in den nächsten
Tagen doch noch nimmt.
Die Informationen der Bergführer,
die zurückkommen, sind wichtig.
Ich muss aber sagen,
dass ich nur diejenigen frage ...
... die wissen, worüber sie reden.
Turbo z.B. ist jedes Jahr
gegen 20-mal am Matterhorn.
Und er ist gleich alt wie ich.
Bei ihm weiss ich, dass er mir die
Auskunft gibt, die ich haben muss.
Martin
wird somit für die nächsten Tage
vorerst keine Warnung
für die Bergsteiger aussprechen,
nicht mehr aufs Matterhorn zu gehen.
Es ist Samstagmittag.
Bergführer David Fasel
ist mit den Frauen zurück vom Berg.
Es war super. Mega.
Das ist einfach etwas vom Besten.
Hinauf brauchte es
schon ein bisschen Schnauf.
Aber es ist gut gegangen,
wir waren in besten Händen.
Hier ist eigentlich
der richtige Gipfel.
Tipptopp!
- Es war super. Merci!
7 Std. 15 Min.,
mit etwa 3 Min. Pause.
Sind die Spaghetti hier?
Hier hat es noch Käse.
Noch die Suppe.
- Hier kommt noch eine Suppe.
Auch der zweite Franzose kommt an.
Es war hart.
Aber wir haben es geschafft.
Der Abstieg
war härter als der Aufstieg.
Die Beine, die Knie ...
Man muss sich wirklich gut
vorbereiten, sonst geht es nicht.
* Husten *
Nach gut 10 Std.
tauchen auch der 14-jährige Linus
und sein Vater auf.
Gratuliere!
- Danke!
Gut gewesen?
- Ja, sehr schön.
Schwierig?
Ja, das Schwierigste,
das ich bis jetzt gemacht habe.
Wie war es? War es streng?
Ja.
Ich war zwei Jahre später oben.
Das erste Mal ging ich auch
mit meinem Vater - als 16-Jähriger.
Mein Vater ging hier
ein paarmal hoch und runter.
Er war 650-mal oben.
Wirklich? So viel
bringe ich nicht auf die Reihe.
Es wird Abend in der Hütte,
doch es gibt ein Problem.
Wir haben den Verdacht,
dass zwei Personen biwakieren
oder zelten. Das dürfen sie nicht.
Unsere Kinder
sind die Pantoffelpolizei,
wie wir sie nennen.
Sie scheuchen und jagen sie,
um ihnen Angst zu machen.
Ich muss atmen.
Anscheinend sind es zwei Iraner, die
draussen die Nacht verbringen wollen.
Habt ihr vor, hier zu zelten?
Nein, wir warten, bis es 1 Uhr ist.
2, 3 Std. später wollen wir los.
Hier dürft ihr nicht schlafen.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Auch wegen dem aufs WC gehen.
Ganz sicher?
Wenn ihr hier aufs WC geht,
gelangt das ins Wasser.
Dann ist das Wasser
in der Hörnlihütte ...
Wo denn?
- Als Trinkwasser.
Es gelangt in die Gletscher
und dann in die Hütte.
Das ist der Grund, weshalb
das Campen hier verboten ist.
Wir wollen nicht böse sein.
- Nein, alles gut.
Wenn ihr hierbleibt,
müsst ihr nachher Geld bezahlen.
Wenn ihr hier schläft,
gibt es eine Busse.
Wir bedanken uns für die Info
und gehen gleich runter.
Letztlich schlafen sie trotzdem
hier hinter einem Stein.
Es ist immer dasselbe.
Am nächsten Tag:
Wieder ruft der Berg.
Ciao zusammen! Einen schönen Tag!
* Lachen *
Und weg.
Sind die nicht bereits falsch?
Wieder ein heisser Tag
mit Plustemperaturen
bis fast 5'000 m.
Auch Jan, den Wissenschaftler,
zieht es heute ans Matterhorn
zu den Bewegungssensoren
am Hörnligrat.
Dorthin, wo im letzten Hitzesommer
der Felsabbruch war.
Noch ist der Berg ruhig.
Entwarnung
gibt der Wissenschaftler aber nicht.
Wenn es wirklich ganz grosse, starke
und schnelle Niederschläge gibt -
und das jeden Tag -
oder vielleicht auch Dauerregen,
dann haben wir schon ein Problem.
Wenn das Wasser
auf den warmen Fels trifft,
schmilzt in der Tiefe
nochmals viel mehr Eis.
Martin Lehner kontrolliert auch heute
seine Wasserfassung.
Diesmal von weiter unten.
Mal schauen.
Wasser kommt noch,
Zulauf ist noch gegeben.
* Grollen am Berg *
Das ist Eis, das abbricht.
Die Gletscher
gehen seit ungefähr 1860 zurück.
Aber sicher nicht so schnell
wie in den letzten 15 Jahren.
Seit ich mich erinnern kann,
gehen sie zurück.
Das sagte schon mein Vater.
Damals waren sie
natürlich noch viel weiter vorne.
Jetzt sieht man,
wie sie verschwinden.
Vorher sah man,
wie sie kleiner wurden,
jetzt sieht man sie verschwinden.
Das gibt einem zu denken.
Jetzt hoffen wir, dass es diesen
Sommer noch genügend Wasser hat.
Eine so grosse und moderne Hütte
wie die Hörnlihütte
braucht einfach viel zu viel Wasser.
Seine Frau Edith wird die nächsten
Tage nochmals gefordert sein.
Bis 19 Uhr tauen die schon noch auf.
Ich habe mal 10 Min. eingestellt.
Freddy, der einzige Koch,
macht drei Tage frei.
Edith und Küchenhilfe Peter
müssen übernehmen.
Das schaffen wir schon.
Sonst müssen die Gäste
halt ein bisschen flexibel sein,
mal warten, wenn etwas schiefgeht.
Mein Gott, wir sind alles Menschen.
Tschüss.
Das erste Sommerferienwochenende
ist überstanden.
Lehners haben kurz Zeit
für einen Schwatz mit Bekannten.
Wenn man unten keine Zeit hat,
trifft man sich auf der Hörnlihütte.
Ciao.
Alle Bergsteiger
sind zurück in der Hütte -
nur einer fehlt noch:
der Einzelgänger Moises.
Allein, ohne Bergführer,
brach er heute Morgen
tatsächlich zum Matterhorn auf.
Nun muss er von Bergsteigern zurück
in die Hütte eskortiert werden.
Den Gipfel hat er nicht erreicht.
Er war da drüben am Wandfuss,
Richtung Schnee.
Hast du dich verlaufen?
- Ja. Zwei Schutzengel.
Ich habe mich verlaufen. Ich dachte,
es gehe da drüben hinunter.
Er löste Steine aus, die wir hörten.
Dann rief er um Hilfe.
Wars gefährlich?
- Ja.
Er stand über einer steilen Felswand
und bemerkte es von oben nicht.
Wir riefen ihm zu,
nicht weiterzugehen.
Sonst wäre es wirklich
sehr gefährlich geworden.
Ein Wunder, dass er hier ist.
- Ja.
Zum Glück habe ich sie getroffen,
sonst hätte ich die Rettung gerufen.
Du musst viel trinken.
Gehst du noch runter?
Ich habe die Bahn verpasst.
- Ja, die letzte war um 17 Uhr.
Step-by-step.
- Step-by-step.
Funktioniert die Lampe noch?
Du wirst sie brauchen.
Mit diesen Restkräften zurück
ins Dorf zu gehen und heimzureisen,
ist happig.
Aber er ist gesund zurück, daher ...
... relativiert es den Rest.
Eine Woche später hat ein anderer
Einzelgänger weniger Glück.
Er rutscht auf einer Felsplatte aus
und stürzt tödlich ab.
Just quick
a few information for tomorrow:
3.30 - breakfast.
Please don't come down before.
Was die Hüttencrew noch nicht weiss:
Der Wanderweg wird
vorübergehend gesperrt werden müssen,
weil Geröll herunterkommt.
Und: Das Matterhorn
wird bald komplett schneefrei sein
und von den einheimischen Führern
zwei Wochen lang
nicht bestiegen werden.
Es ist ihnen zu gefährlich.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022